so what I've done then is they've
expanded because my platform now is such
rather than just be writing about myself
and talking about myself I now interview
other people who've got our prison help
them get their stories out help them get
book deals my own publishing company now
guys like pres he's working with about
ten of my podcast guests it's all true
crammed getting their books out as well
right all those good people who helped
me I remember now I'm trying to be one
of those people now giving other people
a leg up especially guys I've just got
prison mmm
what how would you describe how not
necessarily reading but writing has
changed your life so writing has become
my life you know I read over someone
reading one improvement rights in a read
over a thousand books that became the
lifeblood of my rehabilitation and
blogging in prison saved my sanity
writing about the conditions helped me
deal with the conditions and then when
the responses came in from the public it
was like the spirit of those people was
right there with me in the cell when you
say blogging what do you mean by that
okay so when I was in Mac security I
started to write everything down in the
beginning it was about the cockroaches
okay that's how my writing got
discovered now I couldn't just pulse
what I couldn't just post what I wrote
because the guards can open your mail
mmm you know we want to expose what was
going on mm-hmm
but my aunt would visit me in Mac
security so I figured out a way for her
to get those written notes out of the
jail and when I look back at those
written notes now they're all crinkled
with sweats I've sat in that cell
sweating all over the paper with my
little pencil sharpener on the door so
what she did was she came and visited me
I couldn't hand what I'd written to her
because in Mac security she's behind the
Plexiglas screen I'm in a cubicle I've
got one hand handcuffed to the table and
another hand hold
telephone do you remember in the Silence
of the Lambs when Hannibal Lecter first
met Clarice Starling I think so
and Hannibal comes down as that dungeon
I'm sorry Clarice Starling the FBI agent
comes down is it he and that like he's
in like a fish tank type thing right she
comes down to the dungeon he's behind
the plexi glass screen and she speaker
on him yeah it's a bit like that so what
I could do was a property release and
what that means is in my cell I'm only
allowed seven books if I go over there
I've got to release it
my old mail my old legal left paperwork
I can release that to my hand
now to do a property release you got to
get a farm called the tank order got a
beggar guards at that you got to fill it
out and then these Superior's got to
sign off on it mm-hmm then you go up to
the property of your tank or they're
doing the penguin shuffle cuz I'm in
Mexico City so my hands are cuffed my
legs are cuffed doing the penguin
shuffle holding onto my property with my
property release yeah
I gave that to the visitation officer
with what I'd written hidden in it
now the guards are trained to search for
contraband drugs cash string jeez so
they don't know his stuff that I've got
hidden in property that's you know just
written down right that stuff is on the
guards desk well I've got the visit with
my hand so I'm looking over if you've
seen my locked up abroad episode on
National Geographic yeah it shows me a
man you know with the man and I'm
looking out over the guards desk kind of
sweating thinking he's gonna find it and
at the end of the visit my aunt claims
the property from the guard she walks
out of the maximum security madison
district jail of it goes home types the
mock emails them to my parents in my
town witness near Liverpool and
Manchester my parents put them online as
a blog Jones jail Journal not shown
because I think we discussed in part one
that the
our emerging mentally ill prisoners did
I tell you about that they were doing
what to mentally ill prisoners murdering
them no you didn't I don't think you did
say that
okay then I've got videos on my channel
of guards murdering mentally ill
prisoners including war veterans now the
cases that came about back then
Brian Crenshaw was classified as a
partially blind shoplifter failed to
produce his ID for the evening meal the
gods polarized him broke his neck severe
internal injuries he went into a coma
and died a month later people can google
these names Scott no burg mentally ill
man they bring him in God stop beating
him and electrocuting him with Tasers a
female guard tries to stop it stop be
near Me's faces turned blue they ignore
her and they keep beating him the
prisoners start to yell why are you
still beating him he is already dead and
they were like a pack of animals they
couldn't even though he wasn't by now a
corpse right but they could not stop
beating the corpse just like a pack of
animals that's all it's just once that
triggered they can't stop so those cases
were caught on camera and family members
of the victims of the guards sued the
jail and were awarded compensation my
question my question for you Danny is
what do you think the boss sheriff joe
arpaio did to some of those guys that
were found responsible in federal court
for murdering those prisoners I mean I
can't imagine they probably got paid
leave or something like that or they got
to retire early ok they didn't pay rises
and promotions really so they just got
rewarded and they kept their jobs
rewarded for murder which is an
incentive to kill our pile always backs
his guys up prides himself America's
toughest sheriff who gives a [ __ ] about
prisoners that's his attitude yeah so my
mom was aware of the
lawsuits and these cases and these
people that the guards had murdered yeah
now the blog idea came from my dad this
was when blogs were just starting right
and we became the first prison blog and
I think would be the first prison
YouTube channel because it started in
2007 my channel I think we've put videos
up in 2008 and my dad had read a book
called the Baghdad blogger by Salem pax
that's how my dad learned about blogging
hmm and it was in the news this guy when
the bombs are dropping on Iraq
he lived her she was describing what the
day-to-day life was like and this was
making news in the UK so my dad read
this and he sent me even an article and
he eventually sent me the guys book and
I was very frustrated at the injustice
ease that were being perpetrated to
human rights violations not just on me
but on the prison population I was
outraged and I saw the people
profiteering from it so as an educated
person I wanted to expose it but into
the tools so when my dad proposed this
blogging thing I was all over it but my
mom was like putting the brakes on
because of the murders by the guard she
didn't not want us to do it so then we
came up with John which is Irish for
Sean anyway and the biggest thing has
changed your name it would protect you
and that's what it did yeah that's how
we proceeded yeah it's a while for the
authorities to catch up with my blog now
is and all my books are classified as a
threat to the security of the
institution in Arizona and prisoners are
prohibited from access in them so my
aunt's got smuggled the stuff out I
thought just my friends and you know
some some few people people would read
it yeah when I got moved over to
Supermax because of more tricks by the
prosecutor the BBC The Guardian ran a
major newspaper here they had an
American cockroach on the front of the
section and it's all the anecdotes I
told you about the cockroaches yeah
that's what got my writing discovered
oh my goodness and then the [ __ ]
amazing
the BBC ran it and it's just not stopped
the media's not stopped since
since then the interest is not stopped
since then so how is it so you were
writing
you were sitting sitting down in your
cell writing daily yeah yeah people
would read my blog contact they had a
blog administration which was my parents
and then my parents was it vetted them
and found out you know they were good
people would give them my prison address
and they would write letters to me and
sent books to me
[Laughter]